Rejoice with me, brethren, for behold,
today is the release date of my new
book, The Two Swords of Christ. If you
ordered it on Amazon or elsewhere, I
imagine you'll be getting it very soon,
and I look forward to reading your
thoughts on it. Now, as it happens, and
rather ironically, today is also the
anniversary of another important date,
indeed of the most heroic battle covered
in the book, and that's saying
something. I speak of the Battle of
Montgisard, which took place today,
November 25th, in the year 1177 AD. I
had always planned on making a video
about this, arguably, most epic battle
of the entire crusading era, though it
was only right before taping it that one
of you, in the comment section, pointed
out that the battle and my book's
publication shared the same date, that
is today. So, what better way to
commemorate the release of The Two
Swords of Christ than by regaling you,
dear viewer and future reader, with one
of its most powerful chapters on the
Battle of Montgisard. Come back with me
now to the year 1177. Saladin, the
cunning sultan, rules Egypt, while in
Jerusalem, a 16-year-old teenager,
Baldwin IV, also known as the Leper
King, sits on the throne of the Crusader
Kingdom. Although his leprosy, which was
discovered only after his coronation in
1174, had been slowly consuming and
paralyzing him, his faith and
perseverance endured.
In the words of William of Tyre, who
tutored the lad, "Quote, it is
impossible to refrain from tears while
speaking of this great misfortune. For
as he began to reach years of maturity,
it was evident that he was suffering
from the terrible disease of leprosy.
Day by day, his condition became worse.
The extremities and the face were
especially attacked, so that his
faithful followers were moved with
compassion when they looked upon him.
Nevertheless, he continued to make
progress in the pursuit of letters, and
gave ever increasing promise of
developing a lovely disposition. He was
comely of appearance, and far beyond the
custom of his forefathers, he was an
excellent horseman and understood the
handling of horses." Dismissed by Muslim
sources as a blue-eyed, freckled leprous
evil doer, their words, Baldwin would
soon display a level of faith and
courage unmatched in his age. Now, the
crisis began when Saladin learned the
Crusaders had marched north to repulse
the incursions of one of his own Muslim
relatives. Seizing the chance, he raised
an army of 26,000 Muslims, Turks, Arabs,
Kurds, Sudanese, and Mamluks, that is
slave soldiers, and crossed over into
Christian territory with the intent to
raid, plunder, burn, slaughter, and
enslave. The first to react were the
Knights Templars, led by the Master of
the Temple, Odo of St. Amand, a grizzled
60-year-old veteran of war. With only 80
knights, he garrisoned Gaza, the first
Christian fortress in the mammoth Muslim
army's march. Saladin detached a force
to besiege and occupy the knights, and
continued toward the important fortress
of Ascalon. Baldwin, though sick and
weak, rallied as many men as he could,
under 500 mounted knights and a few
thousand infantry, and rode to garrison
Ascalon. Considering Baldwin's failing
condition, everyone despaired of the
life of the sickly king, already half
dead. But he drew upon his courage and
rode to meet Saladin. To quote from the
Chronicle of 1234, "By November 22nd,
Saladin had surrounded Ascalon.
The sight of the vastly outnumbered
Christians provoked Saladin and his men
to such a pitch of arrogance that they
paraded about in admiration of their own
prowess."
By the way, unless otherwise noted, all
quotes are from William of Tyre's
contemporary chronicle, which I quote
from extensively. So, Saladin left
another detachment to blockade Ascalon,
while he and his army, divided in
smaller squadrons for maximum damage,
went off in all directions to wreak
havoc among the now defenseless
Christian cities of the Holy Land. One
of Saladin's commanders, the Armenian
traitor Jovalino, abandoning the faith
of the mediator between God and man,
that is Christ, had converted to Islam
and was following devious ways, writes
William. He torched Ramla to the ground,
and with showers of arrows and weapons
of all kinds, he unleashed hell on the
Christians and, quote, "harried them
without intermission." Meanwhile, great
terror descended upon the people, for
the enemy was roving about freely
without opposition. Even the Christians
of the Kingdom of Jerusalem itself were
also on the verge of evacuating the city
as the Muslim, quote, "marauders" had
spread over almost the entire surface of
the plain. Now was the appearance of
this region desolate and overwhelmed
with bitterness. On learning of the
devastation Saladin was causing
throughout his realm, young Baldwin,
still holed up in Ascalon, decided to
try the dubious chances of battle with
the enemy than to suffer his people to
be exposed to rape, fire, and massacre.
Although he was vastly outnumbered, he
managed to break through the blockade,
and before that, he also sent word to
Odo, who was himself holed up with his
80 Templars in Gaza, to also break
through their blockade and meet him,
which the Master and his Templars did.
Once the two Christian forces converged,
and now reinforced by a band of
ultra-zealous Knights Templars, Baldwin
pursued the plundering raiders. This
despite the fact that the Crusaders only
amounted to perhaps 3,000 fighters,
mounted knights and infantry, against
26,000 Muslims, meaning the Christians
were outnumbered by about nine to one.
Everywhere they were met with devastated
towns, massacred Christians, and
churches set aflame as they followed in
hot pursuit of the Muslims.
Finally, on November 25th, they tracked
down a large Muslim force near
Montgisard, between Ramla and Yibna. It
happened to be the very one Saladin
himself was leading. The Christians
advanced, quote, "intent on the one
purpose of avenging their wrongs. The
sight of the fires on every side and the
reports of the massacre of their people
inspired them with divine courage, and
they hastened on as one man." Saladin
immediately recalled the rest of his
marauding troops, and, quote, "the
enemy's forces who had ventured some
distance away to seek booty and spread
fires began to arrive from different
directions, a circumstance which greatly
increased Saladin's strength. Then, by
the sound of the trumpet and the roll of
the drums, the sultan sought to
encourage his men for the conflict and
to rouse them by his words, laden as
they were with typical jihadist and
anti-Christian rhetoric. Over at the
Christian camp, something both similar
and different was happening. Wrapped in
bandages and supporting his frail weight
on a staff, the wearied Leper King and
his men were on their knees before the
True Cross, imploring God for aid. This
ritual concluded, and despite their
vastly outnumbered status, the
Christians arose with a renewed spirit,
says William.
Quote, "Had not the Lord, who never
fails those who put their trust in him,
graciously inspired our men with inward
courage, the Christians would have been
driven to despair, not only of victory,
but of liberty and safety as well, due
to the overwhelming number of the enemy.
However, they nonetheless drew up their
forces in battle array, and arranged
their lines according to military rules,
disposing in proper order those who were
to make the first attack and the
reserves who were to come to their aid."
First listed in William's battle array
were Christendom's crack troops. Quote,
"Odo of St. Amand, the Master of the
Knights Templars, and 80 of his
brethren." Surrounded by the flames of
consumed Christian towns, the Leper King
led the Crusaders into the fray. The
battle was initially indecisive, but
soon the Templars, followed by the
Hospitallers and other heavy cavalry,
began to press on with ever increasing
boldness, writes William. Now the valley
filled with the sounds of battle.
Weapons clanged, men shouted, and the
wounded and dying cried out in agony.
The Frankish foot, which advanced in the
wake of the successful cavalry attack,
entered the fight to capitalize on the
successful charge of the Knights
Templars. Before long, Saladin's lines
were broken, continues William, and
after a terrible slaughter, were forced
to flee. All except for the Sultan's
hardy Mamluks, a thousand slave soldiers
who must fight to the death. And so they
did. But the Crusaders, fighting now
like men possessed, slaughtered them all
to a man. Once again, it was Odo, at the
head of his 80 Templars, who broke
through the guard of Mamluks, slew their
commander, and penetrated to the
imperial tent, from whence the Sultan
escaped with great difficulty, almost
naked. The mighty Saladin, who only
hours before was confidently terrorizing
the Christians, barely managed to mount
a camel and beat a swift retreat back to
Egypt through the desert, where he
rejoined the remnants of his army. For
12 miles, the Crusaders chased the
Muslims deep into the stormy night, and
slaughtered many more before halting at
the Egyptian frontier.
The bedraggled and exhausted Sultan
finally reached Cairo on December 8th
with a tenth of his original army of
26,000. And so it was that God scattered
a great multitude, and thus made it
plain that it was he alone, the
Archbishop of Tyre reminded, and not
another, by whose aid one could chase a
thousand and two put ten thousand to
flight. This, of course, is a reference
to Deuteronomy 32:30. In the annals of
Crusader lore, the Battle of Montgisard
was seen as the most glorious victory
that the Christians had ever gained over
the infidels since Godfrey's victory at
Ascalon in 1099, writes historian E.J.
King. Yet this spectacular victory came
at great cost. Of the three or so
thousand Christians, more than a
thousand were slain, and another
thousand maimed for life.
And although Saladin's army was
decimated, the pool of men he could draw
from was bottomless. Okay, I hope you
enjoyed this true story, which is better
than anything Hollywood can dish up. For
many more such accounts, all of which
are edifying in more ways than one,
consider getting a copy of The Two
Swords of Christ.
Signed copies by yours truly available
at my website. See the link in the
description. Okay, bye for now.
[Music]